ich als ausnahmetalent anders können als
letztes ja das hier ist weiß ich nicht
das finde ich gut das ist gut das heißt
noch nicht dass gekauft habe weil news
drauf steht ja nicht zu viel weil das
könnte vielleicht noch benutzen nicht so
schlecht ist ich finde ein echt sieht
das eigentlich ganz okay auch wenn
danach ein kuss sieht es ähnlich aus wie
nun gefallen
hey leute fast gedacht und herzlich
willkommen beim ein video ja leute ich
hoffe natürlich geht es gut besser als
dein an folgen vielleicht war sofort am
anfang ich wollte euch nochmal hier
diese wunderschönen sachen zeigen die es
zu gewinnen gibt
im dezember hat ich finde ich habe das
hier wirklich sehr schön aufgestellt das
sollte aber eigentlich gar nicht das
thema sein und zwar kommt marie bleibt
und sie hat aber ihre schminke vergessen
und jetzt habe ich gesagt ja passt auf
ich kaufe dir einfach mal schminke und
vielleicht ist ja das passende dabei
ich meine mit schminke kenne ich
ungefähr genau so viel aus wie mit
eigentlich könnte ich mich über keine
ahnung wer fertig sein
auf jeden fall wollte ich jetzt mal
losgehen mir um die ecke sondern
rossmann und da kauf ich da mal das eine
oder andere ei ich bin mal gespannt was
du denn davon hängt und ich will gar
nicht lange aber wir gehen sofort mal
los ich neben euch vielleicht ein
bisschen mit keine ahnung sonst sehen
uns gleich wieder
ja es gab acht leute über das was war
noch mal sagen kann mir das ist ja aus
meinem shop ist in der video
beschreibung verlinkt wenn ihr noch ein
weihnachtsgeschenk sucht oder so ist auf
jeden fall noch online also schaut mal
vorbei einfach ganz oben in der
bescheidung beginnen es los alex schmidt
frisur
ich bin komplett aufgeschmissen
ach du scheiße sechseinhalb stunden
später herzlichen zurück du wurdest ja
wir praktisch jetzt gerade im gebiet ich
habe das ganze schon martin war schon
unterwegs habe eingekauft damit du dich
auch wenn ich wieder schön geschminkt
desto war deutschland nein nein so gar
nicht so war nicht okay also doch schon
ein bisschen aber nicht so viele so gar
nichts für dich okay leute bevor es
weitergeht wollte ich einmal noch kurz
also das passt jetzt halt zu diesem
video
ich wollte eigentlich so hier das dritte
video irgendwas verlosen beschluss von
oder soll ich so dass verluste aber wenn
ich jetzt nämlich schon mal der frauen
jahre stärker dann tun wir das auch mal
erklären weil ich habe absolut keine
ahnung was da drin ist
er habe unter allen die mich abonnieren
in diesem video nochmal oben geben und
in die kommentare schreiben einfach nach
hinten gehen
ihr könnt kommentieren was ihr wollt so
oft ihr wollt oder irgendwie warum wir
das haben wollt also keine ahnung
das sind alles sachen von weg also oder
das medium comic also sehr gute sachen
also wir haben ja einmal dieses klinke
dass es eine pinsel tasche im wert von
70 euro
hier unten ist anscheinend auch einen
pinsel tasche ich weiß gar nicht was ist
jeder
unterschiedliche hauttypen gläubig oder
so also wirklich die beste schminken die
man sich nur vorstellen kann auf diesem
planeten da muss man sagen hat sich
verkäuferin es hier auch mögen beim
einpacken das war das nicht ganz nette
und wie weit ich komme ja auch bekannt
verkleinern um sagen wir mal meine
videos guckt also oder schöne grüße an
dieser stelle so und nach dem jetzt
anderen auf den ringen in der
beschreibung abgecheckt alex lima ich
kann es auch einen schluss gehen
der zweite ich mein wort geil war das
hier sind meine haare sowie gerade
ansteht darunter ist ein genie okay ich
habe jetzt wirklich die heftigste
schminke geholt ich zeig dir einfach mal
und dann wirst du auch einen
schmetterling
was mir auch so aufgefallen ist guck mal
ich bin da reingekommen und da war so
viel schminke und mir ist irgendwie so
mit der zeit aufgefallen ist das doch
alles das gleiche dann habe ich oben
gelesen dass es einfach so fünf
verschiedene sachen sind alles das
gleiche von verschiedenen marken
naja ich freue mich gecheckt und man
muss dazu sagen ich wusste nichts davon
wenn ein trainer eben dazu mir ja ich
habe dir ein bisschen schminke nur
infrage dass wir mit dem günstigsten an
ich weiß gar nicht was genau war
was ist das macht mir die augen hast
hatte man
auf dessen kaltes oder hast du das denn
gehen oder richtig darf ich dann bei dir
anhören und sich selbst für dich ist gut
dass mal kurz so hingenommen
ich kann kurzer gehabt alex hat auf
jeden fall eine schöne farbe ausgesucht
dass ich jetzt alles hätte ich ein
blaues auge
ich finde das gut guck mal kommunarde
hin und schaut euch das an weil ich
finde es echt gut
egal wann egal also wenn du willst
kannst du behalten eigentlich das
einfach wieder so willkommen zum
nächsten tagen zwar übrigens der
verkäufer wird dass alle menschen gucken
so dumm wenn ein junger schminke kaufen
ich stand da so die reihe bislang und
der verkäufer so als nächstes haben wir
super sail bruder ist das gut
was kann das eventuell wenn du dich
jeden tag ausgesucht hat also ich glaube
schon dass ich die richtige form gewählt
oder puder mich mag aber das ist mir so
ein ding natürlich richtig schlecht
warum das wasser einen schönen in seinem
bereich da können wir jetzt freut sich
dass mac paket auch machen aber das ist
ja für jemand von euch ich muss nach
hause fahren
das sieht gut aus sogar mit spiegels gar
nicht so schlecht dass mir ein rezept
also willkommen zur nächsten sache das
war nicht mega cool ich habe meine
eigenen aber auch so ein bisschen an ein
paar häuser orientiert wir haben hier
maximum eislers kdh
dadurch werden deine augen viel stärker
so matthias und ich brauche ihnen das
kann aber ich hoffe das ist nicht wahr
okay das ist mir gut ich habe dieses
kaufen können da nicht verkleben ist gut
das angenehm
das betont die augen richtig da guckt
man die kamera wenn ich soweit und es
ist unscharf wird also ist auf jeden
fall sehr viel schminke gerade sich als
ausnahmetalent haben ihr das kommt das
ist ja das hier ist weiß ich nicht das
fertig
das ist gut das heißt noch nicht dass
gekauft habe weil news draufsteht etwas
anders das für immer die augen
die raman alter geil aber so jetzt
machen wir deine augen zu weil ich war
nicht ich sage jetzt nicht welche farbe
ich neben augen zu
was wird wohl schön wenn man jetzt mal
dieses komische braunbeck fest dass hier
noch mal nur das auge zu kannst du das
das ist mir gelungen eigentlich jetzt
schon klar dass man es nicht besser in
warnung streichen
oha wundervoll es sonst gut aus
richtigkeit haben ja ich habe hier noch
remmels schimmert auch bruder geholt
jetzt kannst du hier hat meine man
machen
ich habe schon ein paar gute sachen
gekauft aber die wirkung hatten blut
muss man sehr günstig was euch im schlaf
mit mit der hand nicht zu viel weil das
könnte ich vielleicht noch benutzen also
nicht so sein dann geht das ja nicht so
cool oder wird es eher so eckl
da möchte ich auch mal schön
also wenn ihr möchtet dann alex make up
nein du hast so ausgelutscht was
irgendwie irgendwie schwingt das ist ja
wirklich sachen für dich niemals
schmecken
also okay und um das ganze jetzt noch
fein abzurunden habe ich noch mal ganz
tief und den geldbeutel gegriffen und
habe hier ein finden
lippenstift gekauft hast du dir sitzt
jemand drauf mache mir aber jetzt schon
ein beispiel hierfür noch ein bisschen
aber dann hatte ich das bedeute so
schlecht ist
ich finde ein echt sieht es eigentlich
ganz ok aus aber wenn du dann nach ein
positives echo aus wie nun fällt wenn
ihr achter aus dem garten hat es das
überhaupt machen was nicht da ist dann
abhängig machen wolle
nein nein kommen so am besten gar nicht
mehr hier vor am besten gehst du gar
nicht mehr so vor die kameras ich will
ja schließlich mache ich mit alex kommt
zu euch und schminkt aber die ganze zeit
du siehst aus wie so ein geschminkter
schmettern
also wenn du möchtest das ist natürlich
alles behalten darf macht auf seiner
schminke sammlung hinzufügen wahlleiter
kennen das ist das schönste gefühl haben
praktisch abgeschnitten
das hängt die gesamte weltspitze majorie
alex habe ich ganz so hässlich
geschminkt ja heute als bewertet auf
jeden fall war mein wissen in den
kommentaren so keine ahnung machte
gewinnspiel für alle meine abonnenten
leichtes video kommentiert eben was und
wir sehen uns morgen schon wieder waren
auch schon um 11 uhr morgens und ja das
war super wie könnt ihr mal bei
instagram vorbeischauen die als 10.000
follower mega kreisarchivs morgen kommt
rein